please don't do this to me euphoria is
not an easy watch and it's not an easy
show to film either one actors struggled
to breathe on set while another got so
overwhelmed they needed to leave the set
completely and so did a director we're
covering ten of the toughest scenes to
film from the technical struggles to the
emotional hardships that the euphoria
team dealt with
i'm so scared
number one
the carnival shoe was tough for a whole
lot of reasons sam wanted it to feel
like it was one shot technically
levinson admitted it was a nightmare
six days of dusty and freezing cold
conditions made it rough for the actors
too zendaya struggled to breathe while
shooting needing an inhaler to get
through but considering what they ended
up with paying the price was worth it
zendaya said it best herself it was a
nightmare but it was also the best
number two
that's what happens when you improvise a
fight on set as in day i it's not fun
you know the vicious battle between rue
and leslie was tough for everyone in the
room that day both actors fully
committed leaving no stone unturned it
wasn't easy in the sense that you know
your mind knows it's not real but your
your body doesn't zendaya wound up
feeling so physically sick she thought
she'd vomit you have to go to those
points
in order to
get to the beautiful parts even sam
levinson had to take a beat to step away
and recoup witnessing the horrifyingly
truthful performance
number three
tough to watch you can bet it was tough
to film the intimate intense sequence is
in part so successful because of sydney
sweeney's moving performance but the
actress really paid the price feeling
actual terror while filming alexa demi
didn't hold back with her banging on the
door which really set the tone for the
environment sweeney found herself in
yo just a minute imagining the
circumstances was almost too easy in
this case
number four
can you say intense that's when it gets
it gets kind of icky feeling you know it
took about four full days of filming to
get just right and jokes between takes
became necessary to get through the
tough content when the actors had the
chance to check out the footage though
it all made it worth it what they
created was wild and they knew it
number five
while lordy plays him tough as nails the
reality is he's kind of just like this
really frightened little boy in an
enormous aggressive body having to be so
nasty and cruel to alexa really bothered
the actor the co-stars have a wonderful
relationship in reality and while acting
together was a treat they did wish for
the chance to film some nicer stuff
number six
hunter schaefer's nerves were really
boiling over for this one
who are you
i'm joel prepping to perform totally
overtook the actress and left her
feeling extremely overwhelmed before
even stepping on the set schaefer felt
the pressure knowing there would be so
many people there to witness the whole
thing we're talking around 200 extras
with that many eyes on you anyone would
struggle to perform
now this was an intense fight
choreographing all the moves just right
so neither actor got seriously injured
was a key part of the process
technically it was tough to hit every
single mark and then there was the glass
bottle to consider the actors had to
shoot the bottle smash six or seven
times to get just right and while there
were safety measures in place and camera
tricks to use allordy and cloud wanted
to make sure the action looked
believable meaning they couldn't go just
halfway jacob put on a brave face but no
doubt the hit being repeated so often
was rough it was tough to film but
fortunately neither performer wound up
seriously injured
number eight
sometimes you've just gotta take a
breather filming the intense moments
became really tough for storm reid
the feelings were so overwhelming that
reed actually had to leave the set to
get herself together and breathe easy
for a bit while there was rough content
in the first season as well the actress
found it easier to shake off before
whereas this time around some of those
intense emotions from filming are still
with her
number nine
at one point during the second season a
whole new challenge presented itself for
zendaya filming certain tough scenes
became much more difficult part way
through because the actress didn't know
what exactly was coming next for rue
it's all pretty painful uh
because i care about her after going on
such a journey with her character it's
no surprise indeya feels so deeply for
her
number 10.
filming a hit series is tough enough
filming during a pandemic is a whole
other feat the production team regrouped
and figured out a way complicated as it
was to safely film a couple of specials
between seasons it forced me to upend
the entire structure of the series the
self-contained chamber pieces with
zendaya and hunter shafer were an
emotional ride for the actors and a
logistical nightmare for the crew or who
does not have it figured out luckily the
performers brought their best as they
usually do and the crew took all the
steps complicated as it was to make sure
everyone in the euphoria fan was safe
toughest parts of the show may be to
watch it's nothing compared to what this
cast and crew actually went through
which scene do you think was the most
intense filming experience